Billie lourd is taking the next step in
a relationship with Austin Rydell the
lovebirds are engaged it's real trippy I
don't know what to say
insane Austin shared the happy news on
Instagram posting a series of sweet pics
of he and Lorde traveling together
cuddling and of course kissing there's
no doubt this is a couple that knows how
to have fun together the 28 year old
captioned his post with three ring
emojis writing she said yes actually she
said duh but I guess that's even better
than yes it was incredible it was the
daughter of the late Carrie Fisher and
Austin were first linked romantically in
2015 and have dated on and off ever
since the 27 year old actress previously
dated Taylor Lautner for seven months in
2017 yeah we do that a lot we mostly
just like bite at each other uh-huh
that's what love is right while Lord
hasn't publicly confirmed her engagement
to Austin just yet we know she's not shy
about sharing gushy posts don't get too
wrapped up in it don't like read the
Internet on Valentine's Day she
instagrammed this tribute to Austin
captioning the compilation of picks
quote all around the world you make my
world go round
hashtag to infinity and beyond and
here's the photo Austin posted in Lords
honour it features the couple kissing
with a gorgeous sunset behind them and
the caption I found the best girl in the
world happy Valentine's Day to us
we're hanging with the redwoods today
congratulations to Billy and Austin
[Music]